a tentative handshake after days of
growing
tensions the president of Venezuela and
Guyana met face to face in the capital
of St Vincent and the granadines it's
their first meeting since Venezuela
voted in a referendum to claim 2third of
the territory of their oil Rich neighbor
the latest twist in a century old
dispute over the eso region the meeting
promoted by Regional multilateral
organizations Sak and CARICOM with the
support of Brazil was aimed at easing
the escalating tensions which the
president of Venezuela promised to
do we will make the most of this step
forward so that our Latin America and
the Caribbean remains a zone of Peace as
we have approved but in the days leading
up to the meeting Maduro has engaged in
increasingly aggressive rhetoric and
actions announcing among other things
the creation of a new Venezuelan state
in guyana's ESO
region while also directing Venezuelan
oil companies to explore the waters in
front of
it in response Guyana held joint
military exercises with the United
States great job yet despite the calls
for peace negotiations remained tense as
the two sides maintained their positions
well the dialogue is speaking during a
recess in the talks the president of
Guyana reiterated that he will not
negotiate border limits and insisted
that the dispute must be solved via a
ruling by the international court of
justice we
know we know what this
means this
is all of it belongs to all of this is
the map
of no narrative
propaganda
decree after more than eight hours of
talks the prime minister of St Vincent
read a statement saying the sides agreed
to continue talking and meet again at a
later date use Force against one another
however limited the progress that has
come from these talks is seen as a first
step to deescalate the crisis that has
brought the threat of War back to a
region that has lived peacefully for
many decades Alexander retti Al jazer St
Vincent and the
granadines make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer